Mẹ em chỉ tâm mẹ hai hội vô trường ngoại giao Trung Quốc, cảm ơn chia và thay làn đã sĩnh xa tại tình văn âm,
với sự tham dự của lãnh gạo ngoại giao vào quân đội bản ước,
bù trường ngoại giao Trung Quốc vương nghỉ cho biết các cuộc chơi đổi chức tiếp
bà bên dĩnh xa cự mở, thế hiện, các giám các thằng và cải thiện quan hệ xong phương,
trên cơ sử vấn bán theo thông cáo chung và bên thông nhân năng phương sĩnh trong diễm.
Gông, hai bên từ bước cùng cố lãnh bán khó phục có hỏi đồng chứ đổi xong phương,
xây dự lại lòng tiên chính trị, thúc đầy ca khuyện quan hệ và cuộc bà về hoa mình,
ông định khu vực. Trung Quốc hàng định sánh sàng hỗ trợ các nỗ lực này
bao gồm giám xanh nửa bán, về trình nhân đạo và hợp tăng xa phá bó miền,
về việc các bu chiều và thay làm, lãnh gạo hai nước đẩy ra cao vài trọng măng
bình xây dựa dựa dựa dựa dựa dựa dựa dựa cố, đồng thời bán tạo sẵn sẵn sẵn sẵn sẵn